hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video were back on foreign again and we
have some new content to talk about
especially the new content of the week
which is a new effect the glowing red
eyes effect is finally in the game after
a meme of about two years of the
developers talking about it we finally
have it in the game before we get into
that we got some other stuff to talk
about so it was always like to be if you
do enjoy subscriber for new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes they hear
updates the Patchett's on the leaks if
you want to be kept up today with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner I never miss out on an update
definitely subscribe the channel
and with that guys let's get right into
today's video so we have a double xp
event also coming up this weekend from
August 16 to August 18 you can get to
double xp so if you want to level up
your man Gunder any new character that
you have maybe you just bought hito
carrier black prior or any other old
character in the cast like myself I'm
gonna be playing a lot of gladiator just
to get those extra reps in to increase
the score since I don't have him as reps
ebony on my PC account I'm gonna try to
get maybe we're up twenty or thirty
that'd be really nice doing a little
just satisfied there if you want to do
that you definitely can and there'll be
a sale on champion status so that pairs
perfectly with all this stuff soo if you
want to get that extra bit of Champions
hist a little bit of XP throw up this
weekend it's just gonna help out the
whole process a lot easier they also
talked about tournaments and to lists
and they go over this stuff usually at
the end of the year and it's a lot of
talking and there really isn't much in
terms of data and out like they're
analyzed a lot of things but there
really is in concrete things on what
they're going to do from it they kind of
just show the community some people's
thoughts and what's kind of their one of
the more interesting notes of info I
found was that warden in duel is
actually very powerful he's one of the
top tier characters but he actually has
the lowest overall win rate but this
might also be because some players like
to pick up warden immediately some newer
players so they really don't know how to
use him which can totally inflate the
scale and I noticed this because his
pick rate is actually super high in the
overall category but in platinum it's a
little bit lower as I noticed yeah but
they use these models of pick rate and
win rate to look at who needs to reworks
and who may need to change whether it's
a nerf rebuff either way I think it's
really cool that they do this and I'm
totally on board for it but then next up
we have the newest content of the week
which is the glowing red eyes effect
which I will show on screen right now
this has been a meme for a couple years
Ubisoft tweeted this is a little Jo
image of Centurion with these glowing
red eyes a couple years ago thinking how
interesting this would be and some dude
on on the Twitter account so that he
would actually pay thousands of dollars
to get this effect in the game and
Ubisoft said that this was a legally
binding contract and ever since actually
the beginning of the season this season
with your man Gunther
people have been pointing out that the
AI bots have actually had this glowing
eyes effect when they're in the training
mode so people have been a little quake
in this dude's death have been quick and
his wallet is quake and especially so
obviously it's not an actual contract
but it's just a little fun thing that
him and the developers have had so yeah
it's finally in the game now and I will
be live streaming on Twitch while this
is happening yeah I'm gonna be live
streaming on Twitch you know showing off
all of the effects and stuff for all the
characters playing it's showing it off
gonna be a whole lot of fun it's gonna
be live it I'm probably to be rival
roughly about 5 to 10 minutes after this
video is up so if you want to go see it
that we highly appreciate if you guys
want to stop by it'll be in the
description down below but that guys
have a great history day I hope like the
V if you do enjoy subscribe for a new
accompany informational site or
foreigners that being the balance
changes the here updates the Patrick's
and the leaks if we kept up to date with
everything happening with on the wall
the foreigner and never miss out on an
update definite stay subscribe to the
channel alright that guys take care
enjoy the rest your day hopefully come
by my livestream and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]